15 on your Friday morning what's cool
it's cool well with hundreds of
elementary school kids from all over the
state on one giant Zoom call the 2022
kids vention kicked off last week with a
message from Dr Jonathan Moore the
deputy superintendent of the Nevada
Department of Education
so inspiring to see so many Nevada
students who are civically minded and
involved just like you the non-political
political convention got right out of
business with high school debate
students like green Valley's Alana Burns
taking on state lawmakers like Nevada
state senator Scott Hammond on tough
issues like should the United States end
the use of the penny Alana ready with a
confident argument to keep the coin any
move to eliminate the penny would hurt
people without bank accounts who have no
other option and lack the means to make
non-cash transactions state senator Hamm
encountered we want to keep the image of
Abraham Lincoln alive we can put it on
something else we could put it on bagels
or you know or anything else that we see
every day the kids mention ears voted
with an online app and they
overwhelmingly said keep the penny
your family's safe that's from a music
video treat from the Sig rogich Middle
School choir who sang Let Freedom Ring
by the late great George dare in one of
the driving forces behind kidsvention
retired state senator Joyce Woodhouse
had kind words for guest speaker the
outgoing Nevada Secretary of State
Barbara sugowski who at one time also
served in the legislature we were on
opposite parties but uh one of the
wonderful things about people like
Barbara is we work across the aisle we
respect each other and I think that's
one of the things that we've tried to
show today is that by working together
we can make things so much better for
everyone
all right so whether it's keeping the
penny or deciding if kids should have a
30-minute screen time moratorium before
bedtime on school nights they voted no
on that the whole idea of the event is
to get involved to speak up and work
together to solve problems I can't thank
Senator Woodhouse and the entire kids
mention team enough for inviting me to
be the host of the event we always want
to know what's cool it's cool if you got
something let us know cool it's cool
under the Community tab on our website
or just email cool at school at
8newsnow.com so I want to
obviously the kids said we're going to
keep the coin yeah we don't want Avon a
bagel one egg on a bagel I'm not sure if
state senator Hammond will bring that
idea to the legislative session next
year but what about a donut that might
change things oh and see that I think
people can get I mean but they really
had great arguments there were other
High School Debaters from other schools
on those other questions and they were
prepared and the state lawmakers who
debated them complimented on their
preparation on their speaking
capabilities and it's just a really cool
way to get kids interested in keeping
our country together